in this segment we discuss a little more
the mean squared error consider some
estimator it can be any estimator not
just the sample mean we can decompose
the mean squared error as a sum of two
terms where does this formula come from
well we know that for any random
variable Z this formula is valid and if
we let Z be equal to the difference
between the estimator and the value that
we're trying to estimate then we obtain
this formula here we expected value of
our random variable Z squared is equal
to the variance of that random variable
plus the square of its mean let us now
rewrite these two terms in a more
suggestive way we first noticed that
theta is a constant when you add or
subtract a constant from a random
variable the variance does not change so
this term is the same as the variance of
theta hat this quantity here we will
call it the bias of the estimator it
tells us whether theta hat is
systematically above or below than the
unknown parameter theta that we are
trying to estimate and using this
terminology this term here is just equal
to the square of the bias so the mean
squared error consists of two components
and these capture different aspects of
an estimators performance let us see
what they are in the concrete setting
suppose that were estimating the unknown
mean of some distribution and that our
estimator is the sample mean in this
case the mean squared error is the
variance which we know to be Sigma
squared over n plus the bias term but we
know that the sample mean is unbiased
the expected value of the sample mean is
equal to the unknown mean and so the
bias contribution is equal to 0 now for
the sake of a comparison let us consider
a somewhat silly estimator which ignores
the data altogether and always gives you
and
estimate of zero in this case the mean
squared error is as follows
since our estimator is just a constant
it's variance is going to be equal to
zero on the other hand since theta hat
is zero this term here is just the
constant theta squared and this gives us
the corresponding mean squared error let
us now compare the two estimators we
will plot the mean squared error as a
function of the unknown parameter theta
for the sample mean estimator the mean
squared error is constant does not
depend on theta and is equal to this
value Sigma squared over N on the other
hand for the zero estimator the mean
squared error is equal to theta squared
how do they compare which one is better
at this point there is no way to say
that one is better than the other for
some theta the sample mean has a smaller
mean squared error but for other theta
the 0 estimator has a smaller mean
squared error but we do not know where
the true value of theta is it could be
anything so we cannot say that one is
better than the other of course we know
that the sample mean is a consistent
estimator as n goes to infinity it will
give you the true value of theta and
this is a very desirable property that
the zero estimator does not have but if
n is moderate the situation is less
clear if we have some good reason to
expect that the true value of theta is
somewhere in the vicinity of zero then
the zero estimator might be a better one
because it that will achieve a smaller
mean squared error but in a classical
statistical framework there is no way to
express a belief of this kind
in contrast if we were following a
Bayesian approach you could provide a
prior distribution for theta that would
be highly concentrated around zero this
would express your beliefs about theta
and would provide you with the guidance
to choose between the two estimators or
maybe suggest an even better estimator
in any case going back to this formula
this quantity the variance of the
estimator plays an important role in the
analysis of different estimators and the
more intuitive variant of this quantity
is its square root which is the standard
deviation of the estimator and is
usually called the standard error of the
estimator we can interpret the standard
error as follows we have the true value
of theta then on day one we collect some
data we perform the estimation procedure
and we come up with an estimate on day
two we do the same thing but
independently we collect a new set of
data and we come up with another
estimate and so on we do this many times
we use different data sets to come up
with different estimates and because of
the randomness in the data these
estimates may be all over the place well
the standard error tells us how spread
out all these estimates will be it is
the standard deviation of this
collection of estimates having a large
standard error means that our estimation
procedure is quite noisy and that our
estimates have some inherent randomness
and therefore also have a lack of
accuracy that is they cannot be trusted
too much that's the case of a large
standard error conversely a small
standard error would tell us that the
estimates would tend to be concentrated
close to each other as such the standard
error is a very useful piece of
information
to have besides designing and
implementing an estimator one usually
also tries to find a way to calculate
and report the associated standard error